bonjour miria girard merci de répondre à
nos questions sur rt france quelle est
la situation concrètement sur place dans
les camps de réfugiés au liban doit-on
craindre une catastrophe humanitaire
bonjour tous les travailleurs
humanitaires au liban travaillent
d'arrache-pied depuis plus d'un mois
déjà pour préparer une attaque
éventuelle du virus dans les zones
surpeuplées où loger réfugiés au liban
dont il faut savoir que pas tous les
réfugiés au liban livre vivent dans des
zones surpeuplées c'est 22 % de la
population qui vivent dans des camps
spontanés ou des bâtiments collectifs et
c'est sur ces zones bien que nous que
nous apportons des réponses spécialisés
pour essayer de prévenir la
prolifération du virus alors
concrètement en quoi ça consiste nous
passions d'information toute la
population réfugiée au liban à travers
des veuves et des sms
l'idée c'est d'essayer d'éviter les
concentrations de population comme on le
fait dans tous les pays en europe donc
nous faisons le maximum sensibilisation
possible vous parlez des récents tests
mais les réfugiés ils ont des téléphones
portables oui beaucoup d'entre eux parce
que c'est l'heure c'est leur ligne de
survie fille a qu'une chose qu'ils
achètent c'est un téléphone et
quelquefois c'est partagé entre
plusieurs familles mais c'est vraiment
là la voie de communication pour rester
en contact avec les familles en syrie où
avec le reste du monde donc
notre idée c'est de passer des sms et
utiliser une utilisée en 6 d mais tous
les médias sociaux
whatsapp qui sont beaucoup utilisés par
les réfugiés et dans ces zones
surpeuplées nous faisons des campagnes
de sensibilisation en présence en
présence de travailleurs humanitaires
pour sensibiliser les personnes à la
détection des signes du virus que faire
en cas de deux personnes suspectes
suspectée d pas ce que je vais faire de
plus outre ces campagnes de
sensibilisation comment
évitez et j'ai envie de dire une
catastrophe humanitaire comment vous au
commissariat de l'onu chargée des
réfugiés vous pouvez intervenir en fait
ce sont surtout des ong qui
interviennent sur place pour apporter
les premières règles en termes d'hygiène
notamment
oui alors ong et travailleurs des
nations unies sont là sur place nous
sommes tous déployer notre réponse si
vous voulez peut se résumer en trois
piliers l'information dont je parlais
est accompagné de distribution de
produits d'hygiène autres chazel savons
gels alcoolisées et c'est donc nous ça
c'est une la prévention le 2e pilier et
isolement comment contenir le virus
au cas où une personne pour l'instant
nous n'avons pas de cas parmi les
réfugiés syriens vous mentionnez trois
personnes qui n'étaient pas des réfugiés
des camps surpeuplés c'est vraiment
possible
oui c'est possible nous évaluons tous
les tous les tous les sites
nous sommes en mesure de mettre en place
une tente d'isoler si vous voulez un
abri séparés pour mettre les personnes
qui ferait qui seraient affectés par le
virus pour les isolés du reste de la
population
nous identifions aussi à travers le pays
des bâtiments non occupés pour utile
pour les utiliser comme zone de
confinement si vous voulez au cas où les
nombre s'accroît de façon exponentielle
et au cas où nous arrivions situations
où la moitié de la population des camps
seraient avec donne quand en particulier
seraient affectées alors c'est tout le
temps qu'ils feraient en mis en
quarantaine et rythmant les amorties
zonage des thèses des hospitalisations
exact alors ça c'est trois des piliers
de la réponse est très important pour
les cas sérieux qui ont besoin
d'hospitalisation ce que nous faisons au
liban le temps que hcr c'est de créer
une capacité additionnelle dans les
hôpitaux de 800 lits supplémentaires et
de 100 lits de soins intensifs de façon
à ce qu'il n'y ait pas de compétition si
vous voulez pour l'accès aux soins entre
les réfugiés et les autres populations
liban au liban l'idée c'est d'accroître
la capacité au total toute la population
pour que tout le monde puisse bénéficier
d'un accès similaire à la chanter qui
n'est pas discriminer le virus ne
discrimine pas entre les personnes et
les soins de santé ne doivent pas
discriminer entre les personnes donc
sans grand dehors c'est de renforcer et
de renforcer le secteur public
merci
mais réagir d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
représentante au liban du haut
commissariat pour les réfugiés des
nations unies